well I want to get this right off the
top uh the plug part
I asked my new Venture the thing that'll
finally put you on the map that's right
yeah it's about time people have started
you know we wanted to we wanted to hop
into the podcasting thing before it took
off I don't want to get in when
something's flooded I want to get him an
expression
you know my agents Johnny come lately
yeah Incorporated uh because you know it
was already well I I mentioned this
before on here I have friends who were
truly
podcast pipe like they were they were
Pioneers they were I would I went on
their podcast and was like what does
that mean podcast
um so I was always a little bit
hesitant
and to be the dilettante who comes in
and especially you know I mean you're
kind of are you're
being a known quantity you're enjoying
a little bit of a head start in the
podcast game because people know who you
are yes there's something notable there
yeah and I was always like just I it's
the midwestern shame I just like I can't
come in TV boy and like I'd like to do
one too but I'm right there with you
yeah but then it ended up like Well
everybody's doing them you know you know
it's we've had a fascinating time it's
really
um uh I'll I'll help you with the plug
it's called Uh really no really it's
really the brainchild of my creative
partner Peter Tilden
um who I think I've met I'm sure you
absolutely Peter was um he was a talk
radio yeah for 30 years yeah I've had
two uh very failed but very fun
follow-up series to Seinfeld and Peter
created both of them why I'm still with
them I don't know I'm a glutton for
punishment well the you know third times
that's the charmer yeah um so this was
really his idea but the the show is um
it's a really simple premise it's just
we explore stuff that makes us go really
yeah no really and and the range is
extraordinary yeah
um we we actually did a lot of episodes
as a proof of concept and then sold it
to I heart I see we've only did the
competition oh I'm sorry but it's also
available wherever you listen oh of
course
um but we've only I think we've dropped
uh eight or nine oh wow uh you know full
episodes on the air and how many of them
before as the proof of Congress we did
about a dozen but the format changed
because we thought you know the first
one we ever did was based on a Jerry
Seinfeld it's not a premise of his
observation about why is it that the uh
the stall doors in public restrooms
don't come down to the floor why can't
we have that privacy he does a great bit
about it's a little viewing window for
your sad belt and your pathetic shoes
um but but you know he never answers the
question because he doesn't know the
answer right we went okay funny
observation but yeah why is that yeah
yeah so we found an award-winning public
restroom designer and we got the answer
and initially when we did that episode
he was our entire episode we did 40
minutes with that guy right and he was
great and it was fun and Peter and I
have a fun banter but we realized
that's a lot of time for a single small
topic like that so over the course of
developing it to sell it
the episodes tend to start with
something quite small and they balloon
up into bigger issues so that when when
bathroom finally aired we had three
guests on that and it became about why
are we so quick to surrender our privacy
why are we so Cavalier about that yeah
and so it it starts with something kind
of silly and it often gets you know
rather if not heady significant sure or
thoughtful can I guess the reason that
they don't go all the way down sure
mopping you're you you're the first
person to really get it yeah yeah so it
has to do with it unfortunately in high
traffic public restrooms the mopping is
minimal what they do is they have almost
like a a sprayer oh yeah and the tile
goes up the walls so they spray over the
top of the Stalls it runs down the Walls
it runs across the floor and you notice
there's dreams in the middle of the
floor so all these guys are doing are
squeezing you down they don't want to
have to deal with so they can go right
under since it's all coming down to the
floor they go right under with the thing
with the sprayer wow yeah it's got you
know it's the bathrooms are the same as
an abattoir it's like just let
everything everything just flows down
you know yep that kind of question to me
always is uh well it's like a it's
that's why you join the Admirals Club uh
so yeah that's right you get a decent
bathroom and then you know it's worth it
to be in the Admirals Club just to not
have to because a men's restroom on a
busy weekday morning at an airport is
the worst place on Earth absolutely
unbelievable and
um by the way do you know why the hand
dryers have replaced the towels
it's not because of saving money on
paper
uh uh saving money on labor taking trash
out vandalism vandalism kids would go in
and set the towels on fire
and with enough of a preponderance
that the industry went uh no we're gonna
switch this up
oh good going kids no the world America
is fine
that would it wouldn't occur to me in a
hundred years a hundred teen years to
like oh why don't I set that on fire
yeah that's hilarious come on but I do
think in those kind of instances when
you said why do we surrender our privacy
I think like well that's like a very
modern idea in the first place you know
I mean people were tossing they're
tossing their waste into the street you
know and they were but you know you know
when you up until 25 years ago yeah when
you and I went home and we shut our
doors for the most part there wasn't a
real portal looking in right and we
weren't unknowingly broadcasting out yes
yes so
I don't have this but many people have
the Roomba yes
well the Roomba is a communication
device and as it's going around your
home do you know how it learns it Maps
your house yeah yeah
well it also maps and sends a signal out
about the mapping of your house
that I outro it's like there it is yeah
yeah
um you know everybody has a ring
doorbell yeah well if my neighbor has it
I'm on yeah yeah yeah yeah so it's it's
we don't have a choice anymore we really
can't no insist on privacy but but in a
in a restroom
you you know the the old adage in our
business if you can see the camera the
camera can see you well if if you're
sitting on the toilet and you're seeing
clearly the faces of passers-by yeah
they're seeing you they sure are they
sure are there's no privacy yeah yeah
oh there's something egalitarian to it
oh it's we're all aren't we all we're
all cool we're all enjoying we're all
enjoying the same amount it's shameful
yes Indulgence that's how people get
overstaged right they go imagine they're
all they're all pooping so much